um well i think the pain point is
high enough that
if the pain is high enough that people
will do anything to solve it and privacy
is the least of their concerns when you
know they're trying to solve a pain
point so
um
privacy is way over
uh overdone as far as i can tell i mean
it's a nice topic to talk about but the
reality is
people
generally don't care
you know i think you have a unique
viewpoint because one of the things that
we notice is the community here is very
insular yeah right and so when you talk
to valley folk the idea of privacy is
kind of kind of becomes ridiculous right
we lead open transparent lives right
you move back to kind of the northeast
and you get a little bit of a different
flavor
because you're bi-coastal you're you've
got that perspective of okay i
understand what the valley community
looks like but i also understand what
white-collar boston
blues
yeah well even me you know i'm big on
facebook and twitter and blogging and
photo sharing and all that stuff so
share share share
four square
make is creepy
that one that's where i draw the line
why because
uh there are very very few people that i
want to know where i am
all the time
i don't mind on twitter if i say hey i'm
at the kenny loggins to do or hey i'm in
i don't mind doing that but i do mind uh
because that's me opting to do that
that's giving everybody the ability to
keep tabs right
when you do foursquare
then it's like oh now i've got to
remember who
is following me on foursquare so when i
do this who's going to know that right
where i am
so that one's a little creepy and on
foursquare i only accept people that
that my inner circle that i really
really know
i have
hundreds and hundreds of foursquare
invitations that i just
ignore yeah but let's use facebook as an
example sorry you've got a family
um
pictures of your family on facebook
you've got some very personal things
um are you accepting business contacts
there absolutely you are and so you're
open in that way yeah so it's really the
question of where am i now yeah that one
that's where it goes over the line for
me
let me ask you
um are you familiar with glimpse
um i've heard of it but i don't know
what it is so glimpse is an application
that allows you to send either
broadcast out to a large group or to
individuals your current location and so
it's a glimpse into where i am and you
can put a kind of expiry tag on it so
i'm willing to share with you my current
location for the next 15 minutes
um
and it's real time right it's gps based
and so you can literally watch me moving
across the map
we've talked about you know the kind of
functionality whereby
again based on location and where i'm
supposed to be the calendar will know
that i am going to be
15 minutes late for my meeting
give me the ability to share a glimpse
with meeting invitee
right so you're sitting in the
restaurant and you're waiting for me i
have the ability to say to you don i'm
going to be you know i'm here now and
you're going to watch me make my way to
our location but it's estimating i'm
going to be 10 minutes late
can you see that being useful
functionality in terms of
well sure but only
to a very select group of sure people
right so
whereas with facebook uh
you know you're making new friends and
you're pretty open about who you friend
with um
foursquare yeah no no it's gotta be
really really
close friends that you know otherwise i
don't want them knowing where i am right
but i'm perfectly happy to go on twitter
and say i'm at the techcrunch conference
or i'm here i'm there that's that's fine
yeah because i'm opting to do that
but i don't want to have to remember in
foursquare
you know that i'm saying i'm here i mean
i'm here
or
i guess even with foursquare though
you're opting in to
checking in right it's just that
i have to remember who's following me on
foursquare
no that's too just yeah so we we um we
we
just implemented a feature and we don't
know how people are going to use it
where
um you can do a connection with your
foursquare
and tungle will automatically check you
in based on your locations
yeah
so i'm really curious to see first how
many people are going to enable it yeah
and second
if it in second people will like it we
just took us half a days of work to
integrate and just want to see how
people are going to use that because for
us what's interesting for that
is that i mean we're pushing out to
foursquare
the the location and then eventually
then the idea is to get also foursquare
to push in information to us
maybe i'm overly sensitive to no i just
don't know maybe you're not gratifying
i don't use the enforcement because i
know i like foursquare for
um i'm traveling all the time so i'll on
the foursquare will go to twitter and
i'm on twitter and i see some of my
friends they're on the same flight sure
oh cool so i'll go on the plane and find
them because
some of my friends are on the plane i
think oh that's cool right or i'm at a
conference and people will say that
they're oh okay that's cool
so i kind of like that
and i just haven't gotten into the
check-in thing about it
sorry it's the you know the the assisted
check-in um that we're talking about in
tangle
is really targeted towards i think you
know first of all foursquare users right
who are avid about checking in
two reasons one they want the world to
know exactly where they are and when
um and again a different mindset right
but they're also playing up there's the
whole loyalty component behind
foursquare also right where brands are
now starting to um
reward people whether it's through
mayorship or frequent visits that are
they're starting to reward you with
loyalty points right yeah foursquare is
the way that they're keeping track
um
so the assisted check-in is really
targeted towards the people who are
users of foursquare but frequently
forget to check in right which happens
to me all the time yeah um i'm using the
application but i will frequently forget
to check in and so damn somebody else
will take my mayorship away at starbucks
or whatever the case is yeah um so you
know it's a little gimmicky whether in
like marcus saying
we use it we don't know
um but again it comes back to here's an
application that really does belong in
the calendar because it is event-based
yeah and it is location-based yeah let
me add to that one of the things that
i've done and it's just you know kind of
testing and playing with things is i've
pulled the foursquare data stream and
overlaid it on my google calendar
right so now you've got appointments but
you've also got location and time stamps
yeah and so you've got a little bit of
an interesting visualization there and
so some of the things that we've talked
about that kind of dovetail into that is
imagine a situation where you're
attending a conference it's an all-day
conference but you've got some scattered
appointments in there
as an example you've got a 10 o'clock
appointment
but you show up at the conference at 10
15.
you check in
one of the things that it should offer
to do is you've got these three
appointments we know you're running late
as a result of the time that you've
marked that you showed up at the event
do you want to reshuffle your calendar
do you want to notify your contacts this
is these are some of the things that
we're thinking about at least rather
than okay i'm at mcdonald's and i want
my free coffee right so it relates much
more to time and location
so i think if i were a four-square user
i would want every check-in i make to
automatically get onto my calendar
because of that analytics then i can go
back and see
some really rich metadata as well i i
don't know how much you use for square
but you've got location but then you can
start adding tips right so i'm at this
restaurant you got to check and try out
the veggie cheeseburger
right so now you're starting to get some
flavor and some color about the
individual and that metadata is really
rich so automatic from foursquare into
the calendar cool
yeah right automatic from my calendar
into foursquare
yeah
it's not so cool
not so cool with that right
but automatic the other way that'd be
great give the api pull it in put it on
the calendar then it shows up in your
analytics about you know where you were
i think that's pretty cool right on